Disney movies are designed to be re
watched over and over again when you
really dig into them though you might
notice that they often end with a few
dangling and intriguing questions that
are never fully answered from
nonsensical world-building to some very
uncomfortable romantic implications even
if you've never seen Disney's Aladdin
you probably know how the whole Genie
thing works once the title character's
big blue buddy is released from the lamp
he tell us a lot in that he will grant
any three wishes with only a simple trio
of limitations I can't kill anybody
number two I can't make anybody fall in
love with anybody else his final role is
that he can't resurrect the dead but
then he goes on to say that it's not
impossible
it's just that he doesn't like to do it
not only does that imply that he's done
it before doesn't it mean that genie
could break the rules if he wants it and
he just chooses not to there's some
evidence later in the film that the
genie has a lot more wiggle room than he
is letting on
Aladdin's first wishes to be a prince
but the genie never really grants his
wish at all
Aladdin doesn't get to Kingdom to roll
or in his case a principality his Prince
Ali shtick as Milly a ruse and when that
ruse is discovered it turns out the
Royal credentials weren't really
necessary for a marriage to Jasmine when
Jafar wishes to be Sultan he actually
gets to roll Agrabah but all Aladdin
gets as a parade at one point the genie
tells Aladdin that he can't save a
Ladin's life unless Aladdin uses of wish
but it's at another point out tricks a
genie into granting a wish for free
because he never technically uses the
words I wish that means the genie can
use his phenomenal cosmic powers even
outside of actual wish granting we never
learned for certain how much flexibility
that Genie has in wish-granting but
those three rules certainly on the whole
story 101 dalmatians as a certified
canine classic but there's a seemingly
vital question at the heart of the film
that it never really bothers to answer
why is karela Deville hanging around
with Roger and Anita to begin with if
you have a vague recollection that maybe
karela was a neatest bus or something
you're wrong that's how it works in the
1996 live-action remake
where Anita is a fashion designer
working for karela but in the original
1961 film which he's just an old friend
from Anita school days the two
characters seem to hate everything about
each other
to the point where Roger and Anita
straight-up write a mean song about
how much she sucks so what is either of
them getting out of this friendship one
advantage of living in the pre Facebook
era of the 60s was that once you got out
of school you never have to keep in
touch with your old classmates and their
criticisms of your life choices
ridiculous
you can't possibly afford to keep them
you can scarcely afford to feed
yourselves Anita's life seems like the
result of some weird Faustian bargain on
the one hand you'll have a hundred
adorable puppies and never have to worry
about money again
but on the other hand that one person
you hated most from high school will be
hanging around your house all the time
and you can never ever get rid of them
when Buzz Lightyear first arrived in
Andy's room in Toy Story there's
something different about him and like
the other toys who are happy with their
roles as Andy's playthings Buzz doesn't
think of himself as a toy at all he
thinks he's the real Buzz Lightyear
stranded on an alien planet after
crashing his spaceship which is actually
just a box he came in for most of the
movie this is handled pretty
consistently for instance buzz doesn't
want to open his helmet in case you
atmosphere is toxic he thinks he has a
real laser gun in his arm he even
believes he can fly which turns out to
be pretty dangerous but if Buzz really
believes that he's a Space Ranger why
does he freeze when humans are around
fixing his spaceship seems to be beyond
buzzers capabilities so why not make
contact with this Friendly Giant to get
help fixing a spaceship it might just be
that bus thinks it's a good idea to deal
with the native life-forms of this
strange bedroom planet do whenever a
creature of roughly a hundred times
their size walks in just in case Andy's
not quite as friendly as he seems or
maybe somewhere in his tiny plastic
chest first knows the truth all along he
feels an instinctual need to freeze
around humans but can't understand why
he's doing it then perhaps even makes
excuses for it later it's a shame that
the movie never explores this angle
because we would have loved to see Buzz
that deal with the cognitive dissonance
of not believing here's a toy while on
another level not being able to resist
behaving like one Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs may contain a magic mirror
a shape-shifting Evil Queen and
princesses who talk to animals but the
most fantastical thing in this setting
has to be the strange work ethic of the
Seven Dwarfs in hi-ho the dwarves sing
about their work in the mine claiming
that they're swinging their pickaxes for
12-hour shifts and digging up literal
cart loads of diamonds rubies and other
precious gemstones
and this you'd imagine that'd be pretty
wealthy and yet they're practically
living on top of each other in a single
shoddy cabin with one bedroom one of the
other things they mentioned in the song
is that they enjoy what they do
so maybe the dwarfs are just working for
the joy of work after all when they
finish up at the end of each day they
just tossed their gems into a vault lock
the door and tank up the key on a hook
right outside the door this could imply
that they just don't care alternatively
the dwarf simply might not know that
diamonds are valuable which might be why
we see dopey literally throwing
substandard rubies in the trash their
house is a mess and that's an entire
song about or they don't know how to
clean themselves so it's safe to assume
that no one ever taught them about
finances or maybe they're some unseen
boss someone gave them their shoddy
house and taught them how to build
elaborate glass coffins in exchange for
working in the mine all day for free
that's presented in the film the plot of
Monsters Inc is mostly comedy a little
girl from the human world nicknamed poo
ends up in the fantastical city of
Monstropolis becoming the pet of two
monsters named Mike and Sulley who are
more afraid of her than she is of them
this seems like a recipe a
family-friendly fish-out-of-water antics
and that's mostly what we get from the
perspective of our main characters
however if the viewpoint had stayed in
the human world the film would have
quickly switched genres once booze
parents discovered she was missing is
basically an entire second movie here a
crime thriller complete with crime
parents police reports search parties
and possibly even nationwide media
coverage after boo vanishes with no
explanation into a parallel dimension
perhaps even more interesting however
would be what happens next when boo
returns to a bedroom in the middle of
the night as mysteriously as she
vanished what would be the reaction of
her family and their community would
boos family now be accused of faking the
whole thing with her parents be able to
return to life as it once was what they
suspect the truth about the monsters
that live in the closet at the end of
monster sink when Sully returns to boos
room so that he can visit her again is
boos mum waiting just stuff scream with
a baseball bat now that's a sequel we'd
like to say of all the romances and
Disney films there are a few more purely
adorable than the lion Kings pairing of
Simba and Nala if you want to keep
thinking about it that way maybe skip
ahead a little bit because things are
about to get real uncomfortable real
quick okay and all the normal people
gone just so weirdos left good because
here's a news flash
Simba and Nala are probably
related let's start with their mothers
Surabhi and Sarafina for real lions all
the lionesses and a pride are typically
related if that's the case here then
Simba and Nala are probably at least
second cousins it gets even worse when
you think about their dads
again in a real lion pride all the Cubs
are typically offspring of the same two
or three males in the Lion King there
are two males Mufasa and Skye since the
entire plot of the movie revolves around
Skaar Mufasa being brothers the best
Simba and Nala can hope forest cousins
and there might be as close as half
siblings his whole line of succession
thing just got way more complicated
once upon a time the world of the
Incredibles was full of superheroes but
then the government forced the mall to
retire now they're monitored by the
National supers agency which both make
sure that they aren't using their powers
in public and also helps relocate them
if their identities are ever exposed one
hero has gotten to know the agency quite
well is Bob Parr formerly known as mr.
incredible because he can't resists a
siren song of returning to super heroics
every now and then Parr and his family
have been relocated and given new
identities by the agency multiple times
eventually Parr is given an opportunity
to feel like a hero again when a
mysterious billionaire hires him to
disable his renegade robots the later
turns out that this robots isn't a
renegade at all past mysterious boss
built sets and others like it for the
sole purpose of killing superheroes and
has already racked up a body counts of
15 supers before it goes after the past
so quick question it's the only job of
an entire government agencies to monitor
retired superheroes that nobody notice
are 15 of them are gone missing
seriously if you lose track of a guy you
can shoot lasers out of his eyes that's
troubling for a whole lot of reasons and
if more retired heroes start vanishing
you should really start letting people
know then again given how frequently bob
has to be relocated maybe someone in the
agency figured that Bob having a
mysterious disappearance wouldn't be the
end of the world at least it would cut
down on the amount of paperwork they
have to do some Disney movies raise a
few questions Beauty and the Beast
raises so many that we don't even know
where to begin
why does no one in Bell's town know
about the beast castle wasn't he just
their ruler a few years ago is
everything in the castle a former person
we see all the dishes and even the
silverware dancing that they used to be
people if so did the castle dogs have
spoons before the Beast is 20 years old
a fact that's central to the plot and
Lumi essays drawing be our guest the
vaping cursed for 10 years does that
mean the prince was just 10 when he was
cursed how much it jerked you have to be
to put a curse on a 10 year old and why
curse his servants they didn't do
anything wrong speaking of ages how old
is chip he seems younger than 10 did he
stop maturing when he was cursed but he
actually be a teenager now if he wasn't
the cub or did mrs. Potts give birth to
him while she was a teapots if so who's
his father can the furniture people have
kids this is impossible I know
here we are okay to be fair the 2017 we
make try to answer a few of these
questions but in some ways that resulted
in a movie that was way talk here unless
fun the original of Beauty and the Beast
is great and Disney movies in general
are great in part because they have so
many weird loose threads like this after
all after you watch a movie a hundred
times isn't it nice to still have a few
questions check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]